dr. robbert gladder joins us now he's an
emergency room doctor at Lenox Hill
Hospital right here in New York City CBS
News senior national security analyst
Fran Townsend and CBS News law
enforcement analyst Paul violas are also
here good morning doctor glad thank you
so Travis will you talk to dr. David
agus later earlier this one he was
talking about the life and death
decisions that have to be made when so
many people are brought in with this
kind of injury right it's an ethical and
moral dilemma that all physicians all
healthcare providers go through because
we try to save everyone unfortunately
that's not the case the way this process
goes is that the people who need
immediate treatment who have for example
a collapsed lung who can't breathe
they're treated first and they're tagged
red others who are a little bit less
severe that might be bleeding they're a
tear lower and we call those yellow
patients at the scene we have an
elaborate system where it's basically
mass casualty where we tag these
patients we prioritize them and we see
who could be treated first people say a
person would say a head injury who's
barely breathing we try to open their
airway but if there's not much chance of
saving them we have to move on and this
is what we all go through and trying to
understand and really deal with this
because you have seconds doctor that's
correct decision you have a hundred
people on a scene you've got to be quick
you've got to be rapid you look at their
pulse their blood pressure are they
breathing are they awake you look at all
these factors and another hurdle for
emergency room officials we've heard is
it good Samaritans did the right thing
and by putting a lot of these patients
and victims in their own cars and in
taxis and driving into the hospital but
given that you don't necessarily have
the statistics and the stats on on what
these patients are going through and
whether or not they can be saved that's
right but we always appreciate patients
that are brought in by you know by
private people in cars because you know
these are patients that get there
quickly sometimes faster than EMS and
these are situations where we can
quickly intervene one of the issues is
that the security I mean who is this
person bringing you know this individual
in we have to identify them so at the
gate at the triage they have to identify
themselves so we know exactly you know
where they're coming from and what the
situation is at least so with first
responders they can give you some little
nugget about what the condition is
someone who's just bringing somebody in
the car that just says help really
doesn't know exactly what they're
dealing with in most cases exactly and
one thing I do want to mention is that
we learned from Boston while this was a
bombing is that
there are certain maneuvers that help
and one is that using certain
tourniquets or properly a probably turn
tourniquets can be life-saving now
certainly individuals don't carry these
they may use belts they may use you know
other improvised devices but tourniquets
were something that could stem blood
loss because blood loss is one of the
key things and ultimately that is the
issue that kills me and you put pressure
on the wound right away the racks
pressure is always useful but a
tourniquet is much more much more
effective and certainly you know
precautions you know so in terms of
blood being at the scene is a concern
for any private individual and has to be
and that tourniquet can stay on for a
lot longer and you don't have to be
holding it the entire time that's right
a properly applied tourniquet a wide
tourniquet a military tourniquet is the
most effective and that's what EMS
carries and these have been really
life-saving and especially from what we
learn in Boston Carter mentioned this as
well but worth mentioning again the the
request for blood donations in Las Vegas
this morning it's urgent and I would you
know everyone to try to get there donate
its blood is that is the sustenance of
life and we need it and it's really
life-saving and what we've learned from
representative Scalise in his interview
with 60 minutes and CBS was just the
number of surgeries that these victims
are going to possibly have to endure
over the next weeks and even months
because of the type of weapon use
correct right these automatic weapons
cause devastating internal injuries we
may see an entry wound and an exit wound
I may not even see the exit but it's
internally that they wreak havoc they
destroyed the intestines that can
puncture the lungs cause fractures
bleeding in the pelvis
and this is the unknown area where we
will have to do use imaging tests and
try to figure out exactly what's causing
the bleeding many of these patients stay
from you know months in the hospital
infections an issue and called
hypothermia these are all delayed
consequences of such systemic trauma
that's what I learned one of the things
I learned on Nora's piece last night and
60 minutes the amount of blood loss that
there wasn't an exit wound so that they
knew immediately on the scene that this
could be major trouble because of how
the bullet moves inside the body and the
importance of applying pressure
immediately exactly that you mentioned
exactly most of us don't know even
what to do or how to do that well when
you do what you can certainly belts are
helpful you know you try to constrict
the air you put direct pressure without
putting yourself in any risk but
certainly you know when EMS arrives the
tourniquet could be life-saving
how equipped is a hospital to deal with
that many patients coming in at the same
time with a vast array of injuries I
think it's an important part you bring
up they are we drill for this we're
ready for this but and when it happens
you nobody for this well we can be you
know there's a coordinated effort
between the emergency department
leadership surgical leadership a
hospital in terms of their leadership
you know their organizational structure
because we have to clear the ER in other
words we have to make sure that any
patients that are being worked up or
moved to the floors or other areas to
make room for the incoming patients and
how do you coordinate with other
hospitals well there's different
networks we all talk to each other
there's called VHF or very high
frequency networks that you can actually
internally message text or email within
that network and we all communicate and
that goes to police fire and EMS as well
so there you know there are multiple
layers and categories of types of
communication that are really imperative
to this effort and time is of the
essence and you have doctors on call but
when you have something like this take
place in the middle of the night is it
that more pressing and difficult to get
doctors in and wake them up it is it can
be an issue but they're always trauma
surgeons in house always ready to react
always to have an elaborate Network go
out of communication to all you know
communicate and say that we're here
bring us all together nurses doctors you
know respiratory text everyone it's an
entire effort and it's it's a community
as a doctor what did you think when you
first heard this story you know when the
story was first reported it was two
people dead then it jumped up to 20
people and now it's jumped up to 50 and
possibly higher what did you think when
you first heard the details that we've
heard so far I was horrified you know I
always look at the initial reports and
I'm always suspicious because I know it
grows knowing that the amount of
firepower this man had and what it could
do I was very you know concerned that
this could be an incredible incredibly
number more more involved deaths almost
absolutely this was going to be
something that was going to be a massive
issue and dr. Crowder you know we heard
ironically from a hospital official that
they had just been briefed by somebody
from Orlando's hospital that had treated
the wounded from the pulse nightclub
treating you mentioned the Boston
bombing as well
how Corden is it for hospitals around
the country to learn from past
experiences and have the sort of
hands-on expertise from those who
unfortunately had to be there and
oversee them it's incredibly important
and it's what we do we communicate with
each other at conferences you know we
present we demonstrate our methods and
these methods have to be practiced over
and over again you know it's something
we drill on in morning reports we do
emails we communicate we present about
it and this is how hospitals work we
work together and we've learned from
unfortunately these horrible incidences
that we have to you know have these
protocols in place so we can save lives
we're always so thankful for the first
responders very much so and let's talk
about the distance where he was shooting
they said at least 400 yards away
spraying into a large number of people
what does that tell you about the type
of wounds or injuries that the hospitals
are treating well they're gonna see a
lot of wounds caused by shrapnel by
blast effect not necessarily just direct
hit and so the could be burns these
could be secondary effects of the
bullets themselves so you know and there
also could be injuries from people
trying to just you know scatter in the
event head injuries fractures Falls we
don't know the age or the demographics
of the population at the concert and
that's another factor because as you get
older your response from these traumatic
injuries can be you know much much less
and as law enforcement Paul and Fran
when you first heard the story did you
think that it was going to be much
higher than you know when when we were
called in this morning we knew it was
serious we were told that it was two
that were dead and at least you know a
hundred others that were injured but the
more you hear did you all know as law
enforcement people that this was much
worse than it was initially reported
yeah I believe so and I can just say the
reason why that Gail is because when
with as soon as I heard that it was
going into a concert area and the
shooter was shooting at a distance then
you know the worst came to mind at that
point with respect to what the macro
side of his agenda was why did the
distance matter to you Paul well because
it's well planned out it wasn't up close
it's not personal it's it's not like he
had something to do with one particular
person he was going after an entire
group he was looking for a macro message
and that type of thing always speaks to
mass casualty and when we understood it
was an automatic weapon you realize he's
spraying a large crowd right so that
he's got lots of potential targets
and he's just wildly spraying them you
expected the numbers were gonna go up at
one point is that the safety of the
scene has to be secured so when others
want to save other people they have to
you know their life is they're larger at
stake as well so knowing that they can
do that without themselves being at risk
is often a concern so I think that's
something nice to me can we expect the
president to visit the hospital when he
comes Wednesday I don't know that he'll
visit remember it's more than one
hospital and I think it's more likely he
will meet with people outside of the
immediate area of the attack all right
Frank Paul we'll hear more from you soon
dr. Robert gladder from Lenox thanks
very much for your talk later